[Music]
It's thin and it will like it's going to
be like an ankle swing. It's not bad
actually. Yeah, it's not
bad. Can you hide? What does sodess
mean? Sodes means is that right? Uh so
if you say hi ses hi it means yes
exactly you're correct.
We decided to come to Universal Studios
here in Osaka. How you find
Yeah, Universal Studios is amazing.
Take a look.
[Music]
dinosaur.
You see that walking dinosaur there?
I'm going into Hogwarts.
[Music]
Japanese Hogwarts.
This is I thought this is highly unable.
How did this happen?
The whole building is a screen as you
can see. They have this in uh we're in
Osaka right now. Tell us what you think
of Osaka. There's too many screens in
Japan. Everything's a screen.
Everything's electronic. It's too much.
Yeah, it's too much. Huh?
Let's take a look at it. So, what do you
think of brother? Uh yeah, it's
beautiful. No, I I like it. I like it a
lot. Um like you said, it's a bit
different than Tokyo. It's not as wild.
As an Egyptian, how would you compare
this to Cairo? Oh, Cairo. Cairo is like
Yeah, Cairo is another another thing.
Cow's cow's crazy. This is wild, but
there's order to it. There's order to
the chaos. Yeah. Wait, Egypt's just
chaos with the chaos.
This is a team live
style. Dobba from there.
Give some wise words about your lizards
and whatnot.
[Music]
Behind you. Behind you.
Nice. Nice.
Nice. You try try the wand then. No,
it's okay. It's a nice video.
[Music]
I think it's a Pikachu.
Oh, let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Nice.
I'm going to
get some food cuz I'm hungry. I get
hungry around this time because it's
usually the time I would eat in the UK.
So, there's this place called Family
M as you can see.
Hello, brother. Have you got any like uh
fruit
something? As you can see, it's fasure
time. This is what the roads look like.
It's very clean. very clean place. I did
a lecture today in the
masjid
and you know there's a masid here like
on the main masid I did a
lecture I slept 2 or 3 hours yesterday
and like you know 2 hours today we've
got to go to another city where Mount
Fuji is in a couple of hours so I need
to sleep but I don't think I'll be able
to. It's a real problem. Stupid is a
real real real problem. This is a
Japanese toilet as you can see here. Uh
this is actually one of the best toilets
I've ever seen in my life. Um when
you're finished, then you press the
button and it cleans you up. It's like a
bedet. And this is actually um the
Islamic way of doing things in terms of
cleaning yourself up. Uh the Japanese
have obviously independently found this
out and they're implementing it on a
very high level. Almost every place I've
been, I've seen toilets like this. And
you know, some right-wing farright
people attack Muslims for cleaning
themselves after they've defecated with
water. But this is not something
specific to the Muslim uh if you want to
call it that civilization or culture. So
in fact is something which Japanese
people have figured out as well. Well,
and it shows you that hygiene and
cleanliness is something which is in the
innate disposition of people and
different cultures express that in
different ways. But I think we should
have these in the UK for Muslim people
and other places in the world as well.
And Master Sensei is a longtime teacher
in martial arts. He's won various
championships and yeah.
So this guy
Okay. Thank you very much. Sorry. How'
you? 121 the champ. Yeah. Wait. Yeah.
Seriously? That was 124. I went down. I
thought you were 130 140. No. No. No.
Are you serious?
Is that more video? Yeah.
I think now.
Oh my days. That's good. That's good.
When I catch here, no space. I can't
push this. Yeah. This is like a wall.
Yeah. And then I can't turn I can't turn
this way because my leg is stuck his
body stuck his leg. Let me stop my body
like this.
How to escape from here? This is very
difficult. On the bullet train.
It's not much of a bullet. It's going
slowly. In the city. It's not as fast as
we thought it would be. It's like a
slingshot. It's not that quick. It's
not give it a chance. They said bullet
train. I thought it was going to go into
fire. Oh, yeah. Maybe it's going to go
faster.
That's a good one.
That's
supposed Can you take
Ask him ask him if we can have a sword
fight.
One ki but he has two readings. Maybe
three. Depends what come before and
after.
when I say there's a country if it's
alone.
Okay. There's a
two stations.
This is Miyazaki beef. It's from my
hometown. It's halal.
What's going on there? Who spotted it?
It's some Muslim brother in Miyazaki.
They opened it recently. It's lots of
house. It's actually nice though. It's
nice, right? Yeah. It's soft.
Alhamdulillah. Good. This is fillet
steak as well. Do you eat this every
day? No. No. No. No. I thought this is
the kind of life we're living.
Los
Angeles. Okay. No. No.
How do you compare Florida with Los
Angeles? How do I compare? You've been
to Los Angeles. I've been to California,
not in Los Angeles.
But I think I say Florida's like
California's like little sister.
So what Florida is? I don't know what
this is, but I'm going to eat it.
Chicken.
Is it chicken?
The other guy, is
it right? I get horse in my stomach.
You say horse.
No, you won't, bro.
Allah
[Music]
I'm here in a place I don't know where
it is but in Japan somewhere and um it's
been a fantastic experience. We're in a
rural area outside of Tokyo and um look
Sakur Salam who I've come with here.
I've always wanted to come to Japan, but
I wanted to come with people who know
the country, people who can guide me
with the language, people who can
introduce me to halal food because I
knew it would be an issue to get halal
meat, for example, in Japan. And
fantastic, they've done all that stuff
because they got us the best meat I've
probably ever had in my life today. Uh,
and they've been taking us through all
these places and uh translating
everything that needs to be translated
and showing us the things that wouldn't
otherwise be known to somebody who's
coming from outside. And so I totally
recommend uh coming if you ever want to
come to Japan, you want to come to the
far east, you want to come to this kind
of area of the world to see it's a
completely different experience to the
west to the Middle East to Africa, it's
completely different to these places to
Latin America. It's a special and unique
part of the world. And if you want to
have an international cosmopolitan
experience and really pick up cultural
capital in a manner that you probably
won't be able to do if you just stayed
in these areas I've just mentioned, then
you have to come to Japan. You have to
come to the far east and your best bet
especially if you're a Muslim is to come
through Sakur Salah.
Hands in front of you. Don't kill your
hands. Use always hands in front of you.
We like shoulder
lights
opposite. Usually we compete in this for
guys. They can run like normal. This is
very important. One of the most
important exercises. Why? Shoulders.
Okay. Very good.
Very good. Perfect.
Come from here. Come from here. Maybe I
can do this one. Maybe if he's not good,
but he's very good. Even if I try, I
can't. I maybe open the leg. Put the
What's it called?
Just arrived in South Korea. Waiting for
the
bags. Yeah, we are here in South Korea.
It's green. It's very beautiful. It's
very nice. It's not as developed as
Japan. Um, however, it is very
beautiful. Very nice. There are some
significant differences. cuz obviously
they speak a different
language. They I think their mannerisms
are a little bit different. We haven't
interacted too much, but they're a
little bit more direct. So these
buildings like I'm looking at the
landscape here and the buildings. They
all look very very similar. It's
like quite interesting. I don't know.
It's it's like the same architect
designed all the buildings in the area.
Do you know what I mean?
the these are differences with I think
uh South Korea and Japan. So these are
the back streets of South Korea. This is
way more quote unquote developing. Would
you say like oh be careful this
thing? That's why I can't respond. Uh
immediately I'm just getting some of the
stuff because I'm going to go to sleep
cuz you know as you know we're in South
Korea so I'm having to like get little
things like that. So cuz we're in the
Airbnb so
um I'm in the brother
shop over here as you can see.
So, I'm having to get little bits and
pieces. Just finished now in Japan. It
was a fantastic trip. I went to Japan,
South Korea with the guys. You guys have
seen uh how amazing that trip was and
how interesting how much cultural
capital was picked up in those places.
Honestly, there's something in the Far
East that you don't get anywhere else.
And I couldn't have done it without
Sakuro Salam who are a specialist tour
company for Muslim people which
specialize in actually making tours very
accessible for Muslim people so that we
can access halal food. We know exactly
where to go, where not to go, who to
meet with, people to connect with.
Because one thing that when you come to
this area of the world that you need is
you need to be connected with people
that are like-minded. Getting the
experiences of Muslim people in Japan,
these kinds of things are very valuable
to us. So it's not a lonely experience
when you come here. I think this if you
do want to come to the Far East, which I
do recommend that you come to the Far
East because it's once again it's just
enriching yourself. It's increasing and
expanding your cultural uh
capital. If you do want to come, I think
it should be done with a with a tour
group like Sakur Salam. So, you don't
waste any time. It's like you don't want
to be in the hotel looking at the Google
and trying to don't waste any time.
You're just doing it. Um so, click
wherever it is the link below and you'll
see Sakur Salam's promotional page and
you'll see everything you need to see
and book your next trip.